I'm calling it Night Sky.
It's genius. It's gonna make millions
All the lawyer said is 'He Said, She Said'
He Said's got all the evidence. At least I get to keep you guys now
You get naked in front of them?
Them I trust, they never judge me. They're always happy to see me
I wish there were guys out there like you two.
Be careful what you wish for
'Cause astrologically shit's about to get very real for you
We're talking Transmogrification. *inaudible* I'd lay low
Hey can I have your coat? Yeah
What's...what's this? My name and my phone number.
Okay
We're human now, she's only gonna take one of us
Why are you giving me tips then? Because frankly you need all the help you can get.
You gotta know people skills.
I have people skills. People love me!
It's so nice to meet you
Hey, not now
Are you the one who lost this beautiful cat?
Don't come to me. I'll come to you.
(purring)
Oh yeah that's good
So should we sleep together now?
All you did was sleep?
Why?
Because it was amazing. I felt so loved.
I don't think I can get down
You're acting like a couple of idiots. You have no idea how lucky you are to have a chance with a girl like Emma
Sit
Up
Oh I know. Bad boy, bad boy